do you feel like um
there's any sort of because it feels
like the the base having a moment where
we might start to kind of like
see like I feel like guys like symbols
from Antioch uh obviously Russell's from
Vallejo
um the boys dope I think I don't know if
the boy just got locked up again or not
I think so
but it feels like there's a lot of just
high level energy and interest
nationally when it comes to like some of
these artists like you'll see Russell
going on a lot of these big platforms
you'll see a guy like LeBron James
reposting a Simba freestyle like do you
because I mean I think back to the hyphy
era and like that moment kind of
captivated the country and I feel like
that was kind of the last time that
happened yeah because I think it was uh
my ghetto report card you know yeah I
think it was misrepresented wrong I was
having this conversation with Mr Fab not
too long ago like [__] that kind of uh
in fact my brother you feel me man Fab
talk [__] all the time and um I was
telling them the high fee era was cool
but it made us look boozy in a sense
because people thought that was all we
were doing right you give me uh popping
pills and dancing outside the car yeah
that was part of it that was the
in the jackers they was talking about
that [__] like right we were doing at
that time like yeah that dancing part
that's cool but [__] what about these
[__] that's hustling what about these
[__] that's hitting either selling
dope in the kitchen whipping that [__]
with both hands like
what we were going through at that time
and what we were doing it wasn't
highlighted that's why it was easy for
Jeezy and Gucci to take off because they
was speaking that [__] that was going on
in that in that time frame you feel me
[__] styling and jackers and the Shady
notes they were speaking that [__] too
but it was overpowered by the Ghost Ride
the Whip [__] right you get what I'm
saying so uh
yeah and like I said a lot of them cast
that was hella dope in that era Mr
streaming error by you know or they were
like a little early like I feel like the
pack was before like literally before
the time I think little B was before oh
for sure but I mean the pack like if you
think about like sonically what they
were doing you fast forward a few years
and then like Rack City happens and
right right yeah and it's almost like oh
that was kind of
very sonically similar right to what the
pack was doing years ago yeah and I
think um even like fashion wise they had
pink dolphins right and I think people
won't say it I think um
the AL that La sound at that time was
heavily Bay influence I say it all the
time yeah like rest in peace to the
great tracks a million like right that
sound he was creating I hear that a lot
in mustard you know what I'm saying yeah
I've said it a bunch right I'm always
like hey let's forget what the pack was
doing and what about these guys in the
bay were doing right right right right
hey how important for you because I I
always I I feel like there's a guy like
uh G-Eazy right who probably
commercially outside of MC hammers run
is probably like commercially
like the biggest guy to represent the
Bay right I'm not talking about
influence or or tenure yeah I just mean
like you know representation yeah yeah I
understand she's got songs with Britney
Spears and right um but he was like very
adamant about every tour was like from
the bait of the universe and he would
bring like I am Sue or he would bring
keilani on the road right he would bring
40 on the road
um how like like how big in the
landscape of the bay do you look at like
a guy like G and like you know it seemed
like he was doing a lot to try to do his
best to give back
um shout out to easy salute to G-Eazy
um I don't have no problem with it easy
the thing is is
um
that's 40. yeah that's kailani look at
the names you name but it was keilani
was it was it was like early k-line okay
okay I mean he brought pillow for sure
all black all black he did all black I
just finished Netflix on the road with
him a lot I just feel as if uh you
should embrace that more you get what
I'm saying not uh like I said not just
um let [__] smooch off you but Embrace
that [__] more like you know
do more of that you get what I'm saying
like do more of that like salute to you
what you got going on but do more of
that so you would like to see him do
more yeah for sure [__] yeah right [__]
yeah hell yeah but and then too it's
different genres like
he make more music like on soon he's got
pop pop music pop house music type [__]
yeah I don't know how to spell yeah pop
he's got pop records what is house music
anyway
like house music what the [__] is that
it's a genre of electronic music uh
whatever yeah no no
house is not technical but he don't make
house music but he makes top 40 more he
does have top 40 records yeah yes you
know right yeah but um I hear it sounds
like um I never like heard of G-Eazy
album but right like to [__] with me and
get some money all that type of [__]
right I mean but all black on a record
yeah for sure yeah you know yeah for
sure for sure uh Black's dope as [__]
too super dope super dope yeah for sure
I like um
all black Cadence and [__] he be
different with that [__]